all right let's move on to the next
category next one most degenerative
moment oh god god knows
this this was one of the hardest
categories to pick from i think
yeah there's just so many pretty [ __ ]
degenerate
podcasts look at us look at us look at
us
look at us degenerates here it's men of
men of culture all right let's look at
the nominees
all right we got uh bailey's three five
three three by three
and bond is a true degenerate moment god
that just like
i i was like so impressed by this three
by three
because we didn't we didn't share it
beforehand i didn't know how hard melin
was going to go
i love how much this clip exploded as
well the clip is like 300 thousand views
or something like that
it's actually it's amazing it's actually
ridiculous you did it
because i think it just shattered like
everyone had this image of maelyn being
like okay
she she's prim and proper she brought
the boys together and then she reveals
like this she drops this [ __ ]
bombshell a degenerate
but these videos or videos oh [ __ ] play
it it
monster from the new world utano prince
summer jojo vampire night golden kamui
story of sayon koko sures and hakuoki
what uh what i remember about this
moment is when melin talked about her
body pillows yeah
yeah and i i think it was the first time
where all three of us were just like
gobsmacked that we just there was like
just a five-second
silence where we were just like what the
[ __ ] did we just hear
isn't there that picture of me that's
like i'm making this round from this
moment i think
and then obviously we have the next one
which is uh oh this is just yeah
yeah and it was just like this giant
fleshy it's this fleshy giant roll
of a bunch of cookies
that's all you need to know that's
that's all the context you need that's
the
three degenerate never been on snaps
channel there you go that was a five
second sales pitch on your channel oh
god
i really like a i really like elf girls
and i really like tan
dude dark skinned elf girls dark skinned
elf dark skinned
elf girls man replace every hentai with
a dark-skinned elf
i stand by this fair enough that was i
feel like this clip went very fair on
joey this this could have been one where
he was talking about gangbang
one where he was just being nice this is
a [ __ ] like predator meme with like
the muscley guys like handshaking like
god and i'm doing that
under the table right now that was such
a fun argument i think i think the
hentai episode was definitely like one
of
like the most fun to film as like a as
like a host and
i remember filming this and just losing
my [ __ ] muscles
yeah this is a very good episode there's
another one actually from that same
episode oh yeah three of these are from
the hentai episode
yeah oh yeah it is yeah yeah yeah
because we got like uh
steve handjobs all right uh let's play
the next one play next one
how does anyone get on to get uh get off
to this in like 2020 well first of all
uh i don't really care about like
animation it's more yeah no
[ __ ] no [ __ ] listen i i also saw a funny
thing the other day about mother's best
someone posted on the subreddit they
were like oh
someone bought a copy of mother knows
breast they should tell connor so they
can get a physical copy
and it was like my picture of my
physical cop really my mother knows best
i think they grabbed off google images
and i was like it's mine i own the
physical copy i should let you know
about your own physical
yeah hey guys should get in touch with
this guy yeah
it's like oh really i do yeah it's all
right i play the next clip the next one
this one's good out of context
it puts me off so that's why i
chromecast i'm just gonna message you
every hour now just hoping that i'll
catch you
that's why that's why i chromecast it to
my tv
listen i stand by it it's convenient do
you still do that
like i [ __ ] changed my ways after
this episode came out no
matter how you can tell someone lives by
themselves
living up with a significant other i
would like my partner to understand
what what i need to do like darling stay
in the living room
all right and then there's the last one
oh man this is from the figurine
oh yeah play the clip i remember it
being
way over my budget how much this was 170
dollars
see we say degenerative moment this god
got the w
i know i i i was just cause i remember
you both were playing the game and i'm
just like i just want to see titty
um and it somehow ended up [ __ ] she
[ __ ] solo carried my performance
right sorry did you titties one man the
team has prevailed
exactly oh man this is hard this is so
hard
i'm fine with any of them winning this
one yeah really honestly these are all
just as degenerate
i i can't pick i i'm glad i didn't have
to pick i i i i
hope is that at least one of the ones
from the hentai episode one right
because yeah that would be thematic
oh yeah i think that would be thematic
all right all right and the winner
of the most degenerate moment is please
not me
sit
[Music]
well she just earned the title of the
queen of degeneracy congratulations
she's living by her name yeah
was it was it a landslide was it close
how close was this
this was she won with thirty two point
three percent oh wow that's quite a bit
six nominations six nominations
three point two three
congratulations congratulations sydney
there you go sydney you can you can hold
on to the title
loud and proud no doubt we'll be getting
a tweet about this yeah
exactly okay live live tweet of this
entire episode from sydney